with 10 series and over 700 episodes
it's only natural that star trek has
messed up a few times over the years
whether they're continuity errors
editing blunders wardrobe screw-ups or
other oversights here are some of the
biggest on-screen mistakes you'll find
in star trek tv shows
23rd century con man harry mudd is one
of the first recurring villains in star
trek the original series
in the season 1 episode muds women mud
beams aboard the enterprise accompanied
by a trio of women whose beauty leaves
both scotty and
mccoy dumbstruck dr mccoy's arousal
isn't the only thing worth noticing
about his appearance in this scene
when he first sees the women mccoy is
wearing his bridge uniform which
includes a light blue shirt with a dark
blue collar the camera cuts to mud's
alluring ladies and when it returns to
mccoy he's wearing the medical smock he
usually reserves for sickbay duty
there are also windows behind him
indicating he's in a completely
different part of the ship
the next time we see mccoy he's back in
the transporter room
wearing his bridge uniform apparently
whoever edited mud's women didn't think
mccoy looked aroused enough so they used
archival footage of him without caring
about where he was
or what he was wearing either that or
the space-time continuum was acting
really weird that day
one of the more interesting season one
episodes of star trek deep space nine
is dramatist personae in which a
contagion renders the entire crew
power hungry and violent except for
constable odo
the crew soon splits into warring
factions and after commander cisco
survives a botched assassination attempt
he tries to escape the
station with chief o'brien one of the
first things they do is throw away their
starfleet communicator badges
so that no one can track them as the
only member of the senior crew who isn't
losing his mind
odo manages to manipulate both parties
into a cargo bay where he can blast the
contagion
into the void of space odo warns
everyone to hold on to something before
opening the bay door and cisco
still without a combadge grabs a cargo
container we then see several shots of
different crew members fighting the pull
of the vacuum
once odo closes the door the camera
turns to cisco whose calm badge has
inexplicably reappeared on his uniform
why i have no idea
you could try to explain this by saying
that the com badge's return symbolizes
cisco's return to sanity but
otherwise it's an obvious goof
yesterday's enterprise is one of the
most beloved
episodes of star trek the next
generation the story
changes the trek timeline with wharf
absent from the enterprise tasha yar
still alive and the federation stuck
in a losing war with the klingons among
other changes the enterprise's interior
is a lot darker and the crew's uniforms
have changed this isn't right
it's changed the timeline is restored
thanks to the intervention of the
enigmatic gainen who senses something is
wrong and convinces captain picard to
help restore their reality
yesterday's enterprise ends with gainen
and jordy talking intent forward
gainen asks the chief engineer to tell
her about tasha yar
someone she never met in the original
timeline but for some reason jordy is
still wearing his uniform from the
alternate
enterprise we know this because of the
black cuffs on his sleeves which aren't
a feature of his normal uniform
unless this is a subtle hint that gainen
never really succeeded in fixing the
timeline
someone should have told jordy he was in
the wrong duds
seriously seriously a lot of things
change on star trek voyager
after the introduction of the reformed
borg crew member
seven of nine because of her issues with
trust and isolation
seven is rarely seen fraternizing with
voyager's crew
instead we usually find her working
alone in the astrometrics lab
unfortunately the increased role of the
astrometrics lab
leads to a bit of confusion in season
seven's
shattered commander chocote finds
himself thrown back in time to an
earlier version of voyager
when he tells captain janeway that they
need to get to the astrometrics lab she
responds that voyager doesn't have one
implying it hasn't been built yet
voyager doesn't have an astrometrics lab
but this isn't the case while we never
see the astrometrics lab before seven
comes on board
it was always a part of the ship in
season four's revulsion chicote
orders kim and seven to update the lab
because it hasn't been upgraded since
before the events of the series premiere
how could it have been upgraded if it
didn't exist
it's a long story one of the most unique
episodes of star trek enterprise is
season two's carbon
creek a huge chunk of it doesn't even
feature the regular cast
jolene blaylock does double duty playing
both the vulcan first officer to paul
and topal's ancestor tamir de paul tells
the story of how a small group of
vulcans
including tamir crashed in the united
states in the 1950s and were forced to
pose as humans
would you like to hear the story tamir
initially tries to keep her distance
from the earthlings around her but
eventually finds herself becoming
sympathetic
to them and even involved in their lives
just as scottie sells the secret of
transparent aluminum in star trek iv
the voyage home tamir takes a trip to
pittsburgh in 1957
and sells the secret of velcro so she
can help a human boy pay for his college
tuition
the only problem with this detail is
that not only did someone else invent
velcro
but it was patented in 1952 and was
already in use in the united states by
1957.
obviously 50s kids weren't securing
their sneakers with it yet
but it was still out there do you
realize you've just rewritten our
history books
father-son relationships are a major
theme in ds9
usually represented by the love between
ben cisco and his son jake
but in a season 4 two-parter that
relationship expands to include ben's
father
joseph cisco we meet the stubborn but
charismatic restaurant owner when ben is
summoned to earth to brief starfleet on
the growing threat of the dominion
the only problem is that earlier in the
series we're led to believe joseph cisco
is dead ben never outright says he's
deceased but
all the statements he makes about his
father before season 4 strongly imply
he's already passed on
for example in both the series premiere
and season two's paradise
ben refers to his father in the past
tense he says
well my father was a chef also in season
two's the alternate
ben tells odo of an illness his father
suffered strongly implying he died from
it
ds9 never provides an explanation for
this discrepancy but regardless
joseph is a beloved character who
continued to appear in the series
regularly and were glad he was around to
see it through
you up for a stroll with your old man
i can't think of anything i'd rather do
written by the acclaimed science fiction
author harlan ellison the city on the
edge of forever is often considered one
of the best
episodes of any star trek series as well
as one of the saddest episodes in the
franchise
but even here there's a blink and you'll
miss it error that could take you out of
the story pretty fast
the story transports mccoy spock and
captain kirk back in time to the great
depression
kirk and spock's search for mccoy whose
actions they fear have deeply harmed
the timeline the pair secure an
apartment as their base of operations
and it's this apartment building that
provides the episode with its goof
we have a flop we have a white cap a
place to sleep
after a scene in which a homeless man
accidentally vaporizes himself with
mccoy's phaser the camera cuts to the
exterior of kirk and spock's building
on the right side of the building you
can clearly see a yellow sign indicating
that the structure contains a bomb
shelter in case of nuclear attack
such signs didn't exist until the 1960s
at which point the great depression had
been over for decades
that's very strange season 4 of ds9
brings an old friend back to trektv in
the season 4 premiere the way of the
warrior the klingon wharf
is sent to the space station on special
assignment and by the end of the episode
he's
a member of captain cisco's senior staff
but along the way wharf makes at least
one statement that doesn't hold up to
scrutiny
i am not interested in your conclusions
aboard the defiant cisco orders the
ship's cloaking device
on loan from the romulans to be
activated wharf seems uneasy and when
cisco asks him
why the klingon responds it is just
i have never been on a federation
starship that had a cloaking device
it is a little strange
the thing is this isn't actually the
first time wharf's been aboard a
federation ship with a cloaking device
toward the end of the tng season 7
episode the pegasus the enterprise uses
a salvaged romulan cloaking device
and wharf is on the bridge when it
happens you could argue that the
enterprise is only briefly cloaked in
the pegasus
and he forgets about it but wharf is a
pretty detail-oriented guy
he doesn't forget his klingon operas and
he wouldn't forget being cloaked on the
enterprise
in tng's the host the trill diplomat
odon is
badly injured and the enterprise crew
discovers a slug-like creature
living inside him with whom he shares a
symbiotic relationship
the symbiotic trills would later appear
more prominently in ds9
in the form of main characters jadsya
dax and esri dax
however there are huge discrepancies
between what we learn about the trill in
the host and what we see in ds9
in the host odon has prominent forehead
ridges while later trills have smooth
foreheads and leopard spots along their
sides
both odon and dr crusher say that using
transporters is dangerous to trill
symbians
but jadzia and esri use transporters
without issue in the host the symbian's
presence is a complete surprise to the
enterprise crew
it's just that they kept their inner
worm creatures private
but in ds9 we learned the trill have
been part of the federation for
a long time and the existence of their
symbians is common knowledge
it has always been this way finally
there's the relationship between host
and symbian in ds9 it's made clear that
the personality of what's called a
joined trill is a mix between the minds
of the host and the symbian
while in the host only the symbian's
personality exists
odon claims to be the same person both
when he inhabits the body of riker
and when he later appears in a woman's
body i will
never forget you one of the best
recurring bad guys on tng
is data's evil twin lore who shares
data's abilities coupled with twisted
emotions and a total lack of empathy for
other living beings
we first meet him in season one's data
lore in which he deactivates data in
order to impersonate him
the first member of the crew to realize
something is wrong is wesley crusher who
notices that lore
while disguised as data speaks using
contractions
like can't instead of cannot or i'm
instead of i
am this is strange to wesley because
data never uses contractions
yes i do use language more formally than
lore
the only problem is that data totally
uses contractions
clearly the no contraction rule isn't
established before data lore
in the season premiere data jokes about
q saying
at least we're acquainted with the judge
captain later in the same episode
questioned by the elderly mccoy about
his strange demeanor
data says i'm an android in fact the
rule doesn't seem to be set in stone
even after the contraction rule is
established in datalore
he tells picard quote i'm fine at the
end of the episode and continues to
occasionally use contractions in
subsequent episodes
in the end it all works out and lore's
schemes are foiled the real lesson here
is that you shouldn't try to take your
brother's place or
wesley crusher will make up lies about
you shut up wesley
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
star trek are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]